SUZANNE FREY: Oh, ye
techmakers, ye world changers.
On behalf of Google, I am so
excited to welcome you here
today to connect, to
celebrate, and even
to do some creating that is all
part of this ongoing movement
to the way we shift time,
and the impact that we
are having in this world.
I'm excited to
celebrate techmakers,
I'm excited to celebrate
International Women's Day.
And while International Women's
Day was absolutely created
to foster and raise the
visibility of women,
the conversation
we are having today
and the movement of
which you are all a part
is absolutely
inclusive of everyone.
All genders, all religions,
all perspectives.
Diversity matters a ton
in making all the things
we want to do happen.
Now before I get
into this, I do want
to make a brief apology that
we're not having this at night
so we could have projected
this session on the moon.
Mary Lou Jefferson is
definitely a role model here.
She's done some amazing work.
And those are the
kinds of crazy things
that people are doing,
that all of you are doing.
I'm just so excited
and so energized
by the potential
energy in this room.
So yes, actually we do believe
that diversity matters.
I'm so excited to see so many
other companies in the Bay Area
and around the world
also recognize this.
Just look outside your window.
Look outside to
nature, and you know
that we have all come
from the result of a very
diverse ecosystem.
Ecosystems do not thrive
without diversity.
In fact, if you eliminate
certain species,
certain perspectives, et cetera,
the whole does not thrive.
Those companies
that have-- we all
know the stats, the companies
that have more women on boards
and-- we've heard all of those.
Hopefully we can all
repeat them very,
very easily-- they
actually perform better.
But it's actually the teams that
bring more diverse perspectives
to the table and make a huge
difference in this world.
And so that really,
really, really excites me,
that folks are recognizing this,
and this movement continues
to grow stronger and stronger.
I want to talk briefly
about women techmakers.
Megan Smith, another
huge role mode of mine.
I remember the
first time I heard
her get up to a mic at a--
we have these TGIF sessions
at Google.
Every week our leaders actually
get up in front of the company
and answer any question
that folks have.
But they also allow you
to engage in conversation
and tell us what happened
at the company this week.
And I remember Megan stood
up in one of my early days
at the company and asked just
this really great question.
I was like, who is that?
And of course, Megan has gone
on to do some amazing things.
Megan Smith is an entrepreneur.
Key, key catalyst in
our GoogleX initiatives,
and now the CTO of the US.
Very proud moment for us,
for techmakers as a whole.
And Natalie Villa-Lobos,
who will be speaking with us
a few times later today, who
is our women in technology
advocate.
She just stepped forward,
and she'll tell her story,
and said, I think this matters.
And I really want
this to be my job.
And VP, Hiroshi, here at
the company-- in Android--
says, of course.
That makes all the
sense in the world.
What an awesome, awesome,
awesome opportunity,
both for her, this
company, but for all of you
in the room who are part
of this conversation,
doing great things
at every company.
So inclusivity is
important today.
It's not about Google.
This is not about
any given company.
This is about the work we
are all doing together.
So I'd like, actually,
to understand,
and get some audience
participation at this time.
We rarely get
together like this.
We don't have these
opportunities very often.
And I'd like to understand what
gets you excited about what
you're doing.
I would like to understand what
changes you would like to see
in the work that we are doing.
What's not been invented yet?
And we have mics
placed, I believe.
People are carrying
mics throughout
to answer or get some
feedback from folks.
Men, don't be shy.
MC: Ladies and gentlemen,
we have mic runners.
If you raise your
hands, a microphone
will be brought to you, and
we can participate in Q&A.
SUTAPA BANSAL: Thank you.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Sutapa Bansal.
Really got to be here today.
And thanks, Google,
for hosting this event.
Really good to see
a lot of women here.
Usually, I go to
the conferences,
and 1% to 2% women are there.
So, really happy.
[APPLAUSE]
And what gets me excited is
solving world's problems,
solving my customer problems.
I'm a product manager,
so what motivates
me is talking to
customers, listening
to what their problems
are, and then coming up
with products, developing
products, which
helps their problems.
Thank you.
SUZANNE FREY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Anita
Rivas, and I really
just want to say I came
here to get motivated.
And so I like, so
far, what I'm hearing.
But what gets me
motivated is I've
worked with a lot of
children in the past.
Ever since I've
been little, I've
always been trying to work
with kids of a younger age.
And that gets me motivated.
It gets me motivated to do
better myself, and continue
to be a mentor
for some of these,
whether it's boys, girls.
Right now I'm focusing
more on young girls.
So that's one key
thing that gets
motivated on a personal level.
On a professional
level, definitely, I
get motivated when I see
teams coming together.
When we can actually make
something, when I know that,
alone, we can't do it by
ourselves, neither as females,
or in the male-dominated world.
So I like the sense of
teamwork and building.
That gets me really excited.
SUZANNE FREY: Awesome.
And I'm excited
for you to hear--
AUDIENCE: I do want
to say, what I'd
like to see that hasn't
been invented, as part
of my thing-- I
would love, when we
talk about cafes of
technology-- it's been wonderful
when you're traveling.
And you can stop by a
cafe and get connected,
and send pictures to
your family or whatever.
But I would love to see cafes
where they have technology
where children that
can't afford to have
a computer at their
home can log in, and be
able to access it, and do
homework, and do all that.
Because we're so behind on that.
And so that's what I would
like to be able to see,
something affordable that
could be made available.
SUZANNE FREY: Awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
And I'm excited for you to hear
a bit more from Pavni Diwanji
later today.
She's been behind YouTube
for Kids effort and launch.
And she's done some amazing
work in the children's space.
I love the idea.
Keep those ideas coming.
LAURA KELLY: Hi.
I'm Laura Kelly.
I'm a software engineer at an
early-stage startup up called
[? Frame Data. ?] And
we use machine learning
to predict user behavior.
And the thing that gets me
really excited about technology
is pushing the bounds
of product and pushing
the bounds of technology
in new ways that
haven't been done before.
And I'm really interested in
hearing from more women who
are working on interesting tech
and interesting products that
are going into
boundaries where we
haven't been able to
accomplish those things yet.
And now's the time to do it.
SUZANNE FREY: Awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is Rasha.
And what gets me
excited is a challenge.
I always surround myself with
people who are better than me,
because it pushes me to learn.
And I love the events and
gatherings like these,
because I meet lot
of people like this.
I came here to the
United States a year go.
I didn't know anyone.
And I went to every event
that's there in Silicon Valley,
and now I know tons of people.
And I learned so much
more than the five years
in college in this
just one year.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Good
morning, everyone.
This is
[? Menaliki Serker. ?] I'm
flying here all the
way from Austin.
I work for Dell Computers
in the validation group.
So I do testing of
our laptops, desktops,
all the products that reach
you guys and the consumers.
Getting quality products to
the customer is my passion.
I don't want any products in the
field that have issues on them.
So that's what drives me
on my day to day basis.
I applied for this conference.
And what I wrote in, it was
that-- I have seen women
suppressed at several levels.
Especially, I come
from India, and it
is a male dominant society.
And it will stay that way until
the mentality of each and every
person changes.
I really don't like to see
that and I have always raised
my voice against it whenever
I have seen such situations.
And I truly believe that
women are very powerful.
And my reason to
say that, even more,
has become stronger, especially
after that I had my two kids.
I have a three-year-old
and an eight-months-old.
And I think if God trusted women
to give birth to a kid and go
through that entire excruciating
labor pain process--
if a woman can go through that,
there's nothing that she cannot
do.
So I'm here to get motivated
and meet other women.
I'm super passionate about it.
And what I would like to
see and do more, personally,
from my side, is also
work with underprivileged.
Not many people are fortunate.
And I really want our
computers and technology
to reach to all that strata
of society that don't
have access to it right now.
So that's certainly
something that I
think we are missing yet.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name's Christina.
And what got me
really-- goodness,
and I'm not knocking
over chairs.
That's how excited I am.
What got me most
excited about technology
is the connection aspect.
That is so awesome to me.
A year ago, I
decided I was going
to run here from New York.
And I was just no nobody.
I didn't have a big network.
And I was able to launch
this community around that,
and raise a lot of money
for a cause I cared about.
And I had no reason to--
I wasn't a big industry
mover or shaker, and I
didn't have a lot of money.
But because there are
tech platforms out there,
I could do this crazy idea
and rally people to my cause.
And so I think that's the
awesomest thing about tech.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi, this is
[? Shuta Takapur. ?]
I'm a software
management student.
So, as [? Marali ?] said,
I totally agree with you.
I'm also from India, and
I am sure that everybody
knows about India's struggle,
the documentary, which
was on BBC.
We all feel, somewhere,
that we are in the stage
that we need to improve a lot,
and help other women to come
out of that stage to be
strong enough to face
the male dominant society.
And I believe that
only technology
can change this scenario.
Everywhere in the world, it's
something that-- all the women,
they are in good positions.
But still, they are not
able to face this thing
that they are better than men.
We are better than men, but we
are not in as a good number.
Everyone is not-- almost 150,
200 people are sitting here.
But there are so
many women out there
who are not as lucky as us.
So I want to do something which
only makes everyone strong.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Jasmine, and I'm a computer
science student at UC Berkeley.
And something that really
excites me is learning.
Learning computer
science, learning math,
and just having my brain
expanded in ways I never
knew before was possible.
And I think something that
I would really, really like
to see in the future is not
only more female leaders
in the industry, but
more women in academia.
I haven't yet had a
math or computer science
female professor.
And that's something that
I would really value.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi I'm
[? Ujuella Konkerni. ?]
You can call me UJ.
I'm glad that Google
has organized this.
Thank you.
Thanks a lot.
What excites me to go to work
is that I can make a difference.
The team depends on me.
Maybe that's architecture
design, or production.
Whatever it is, that excites me.
And I am a role
model for my kids.
They say, Mommy can do it?
I can do better than her.
Thank you.
SUZANNE FREY: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello?
I'm here in the dark.
Just a shorter way-- can women
over 50 raise their hand?
Thank you, guys.
Thank you so much.
There are some.
So I'm not alone in this room.
Last year, I was here, and
I was very much impressed
with different ages.
But there were not so
many people of my age.
I started as computer programmer
like 30 years ago plus.
And I thought, I will
never program almost
to my retirement, but I am.
And I just have to tell
you, in this technology,
to stay on bar with
everybody, you have to run.
You have to study.
You have to get new
stuff all your life.
And it is enjoyable.
I love my work.
I am software engineer.
I'm not a manager,
never been a manager.
And so, it's investigative work.
It's analysis work.
Woman suited for that,
not any worse than man.
I work for HP.
I am software engineer,
and we have at least half
of software engineers
are women there.
So for me, priority
would be education.
When I came, I came here
from Soviet Union then.
And I was floored when I
realized all of this stupid
prejudice that
blondes are stupid,
that woman cannot no math.
I mean, it's so prevalent here.
I was very much surprised.
So I would love to
overcome it, and to tell
every girl that she's smart.
She can learn math.
She can do computers.
She can be software engineers.
And it is a good
career for whole life.
And I have adult children,
and I have grandchildren.
SUZANNE FREY: Thank you.
We have time for
two more questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Alexandra.
I'm a software
engineer at Polyvore.
And what really
excites me is getting
to build things that delight
millions of people every day.
I think that's something
that's really cool that you can
do with technology, is you can
affect the lives of millions
of people and make their days
just a little bit better.
And what I look
forward to with tech
is a day when technology is
a universally accessible tool
for absolutely everyone,
and they think of it
just as another way
to build something.
And no one has to say,
oh no, that's not for me.
Or oh no, I'm never
going to try it out.
You don't have to be
a software engineer,
but it can still be
something that you can use.
SUZANNE FREY: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is Chloe.
So I'm a master's student
in [INAUDIBLE] University.
So I actually come from
a finance background.
So in my work, we use a
lot of finance models.
And what motivates me to
come into this industry
is that I want to know how to
build a financial model out
of scratch.
So everyone think I am
crazy to change my career
path from a financial analyst
to a software engineer.
But after I come
to Silicon Valley,
I can see with my own eyes how
the technology is valued here.
And how education and
technology can make a difference
in almost every industry.
So I'm very thankful for
you holding this event,
so I have a chance to meet so
many women in this industry.
And I'm really ready
to get motivated.
Thank you.
SUZANNE FREY: Awesome.